HIDA fair warning I'm hopped up on
caffeine and mint you here on this
edition of the Rich Eisen show by the
way great was that it that was a great
yacht rock band right caffeine and mint
you Steely Dan is that right yeah
oh that's the ventriloquist Ian I think
was in the Hollywood Squares caffeine
and mint you this man knows all about
comedy former stand-up comic as a matter
of fact who is now one of the rules
analysts of Fox Sports one of the two on
staff that's a former head of NFL refs
and this man is also the host of good
calls with the Dean Blandino podcast
good calls with Dean Blandino a new
podcast good to see you Dean here in the
flush nice to see you rich you got it
and you had kind of you to give us some
inside information on the Honda insider
report because we wanted to have you
here I mean as soon as all these flags
flew I called you up last night because
here we are now in week 3 yep and
whatever points of emphasis have been
placed on holding we saw 15 fouls in the
first half last night I want to give you
the floor here and let's educate the
listeners and viewers of yes show what
what is happening right now it's
definitely a point of emphasis and in
the offseason the competition committee
got together there's a coach's
subcommittee you had you had coach
Zimmer last week I know you talked to
him they got together and they think
that holding has gotten out of control
so they want to reign holding in yes so
the directive to the officiating
Department is we're gonna call backside
holds and we're also gonna hold and a
lot of it is in the run game what we're
seeing too is hands outside the frame
restriction they want that called and we
are on a pace to shatter the all-time I
mean we're at five and a half holes per
game through two weeks in one game the
record 1978 3.8 per game so it's it's at
an all-time high
typically this tends to regulate itself
as the season goes on players adjust and
and hopefully we'll see that because
last night was tough to watch 10 holding
penalties in one game that's a lot so
the backside panel did the lobster block
is what I never
sounds like something for long john
silver's so the lobster block whatever
that concept is it's it's offensive
lineman basically wrapping up a
defensive player sometimes going over
the shoulders and immediately at the
snap just wrapping them up and typically
when that happened on the backside it
wasn't getting called but with all the
with zone blocking schemes and cutbacks
that has an impact on the place so the
coach you said no we want that called
and so we're seeing that plus a whole
lot of other holding calls being made
right now Dean Blandino here on the Rich
Eisen show and as you point out it it
makes it makes it very difficult to
watch it really does and so the question
is is at what point is there too much of
it and and it appears last night the
person to have actually given voice to
everybody who has been a thinks that
it's too much was Tom Brady on Twitter
it trended everybody saw that he said
he's turning the game off and it made
the broadcast on NFL Network last night
is it possible because we saw in the
third quarter nothing got go Foust is it
possible somebody made a call down to
Jacksonville and said knock it off
because of the attention it received
from Tom Brady's Twitter account well
let me first I was with Tom last night
and we we ended up turning the game off
and so what a coincidence and say anyway
I would be shocked if al River on or
anybody from the league office
communicated to the crew to stop calling
penalties that that would be so
outrageous but it it definitely the
timing lined up where Tom sends the
tweet it goes viral and the third
quarter we have nothing and but I would
be shocking on my time and I think you
and I talked about this in my time there
were very few instances where I
communicated with the crew outside of
replay reviews you me one one was you
know if the game was getting out of
control go back to Josh Norman and Odell
Beckham okay when they you know Josh is
with the Panthers Odell was still with
the Giant
that was a game where I communicated
with the crew and basically said look
this is getting out of control we have
to we have to rein this back in so it's
not it's not don't call fouls it
sacktual e we have to start getting this
under control well that would be the
opposite in a way of well I mean get
this under control might also be code
for knock it off exactly I mean or or
let's or is it possible that a
communication did come to Al to say I
mean how often did you get a call from
the top down or from anybody from that
level of a seat of power in the NFL very
rarely in game would I get a
communication from the commissioner or
someone in that in that seat or that
level okay you know he would come down
and be in the command center during
games and we would talk about different
things but very rarely would he
communicate during the game so again I
think that would be that would be very
unusual for that to happen last night
but it was curious to see yeah I mean
the third quarter there were no fouls
Dean 15 in the first half third quarter
it was just like it was pretty so so so
is it possible that players adjusted at
halftime
I'm serious cuz their wards there were a
couple on the fourth quarter yeah there
was what you know there was a there were
a couple of them but yeah it's possible
it's possible at halftime the crew got
together and they discussed it
themselves the officiating crew and they
said maybe we're being overly technical
and let's let's pull it back a little
bit that's possible those adjustments do
happen but again in an ideal world it's
the two teams deciding how many fouls
there are not the officiating crew but
again it's it's something you know you
don't see that too often where we have
15 in the first half and then nothing
the entire third quarter team Blandino
former head of NFL refs Fox rules
analyst here on the Rich Eisen show okay
so is it possible that there would be a
directive in between now and the rest of
the games on Sunday about all the
penalties that are that that's possible
well the officials get training tapes
there's community
so certainly if the the league office
feels like some of these holding calls
are too technical and not what the
competition committee wants that
communication will happen and and
they'll show examples and say look this
is a foul this isn't a foul and and so
that certainly could happen between now
and Sunday what about the idea that that
I've you know because I'm a voracious
reader of all the commentary about all
this stuff that there has been a there
was a rash of retirements of veteran
refs for either going hanging out with
family like Sean Haugh Kelly's dad ad or
um doing what you do for a living
you know John Perry's now with ESPN we
see obviously starett or TCS and Kali on
NBC these are the guys that would be
calling these games yes officiating
these games how much I guess technically
inexperienced might be at play here as
well there's no question that's a factor
when you have seven referees in their
first two years that's a lot and when
you take away Gene's territory and Terry
McCauley and and these referees John
Perry who were veteran officials who
worked Super Bowls who understand how to
manage the game these new referees are
still learning how to manage the game
and they're learning how to communicate
with coaches and communicate with
players so there's definitely growing
pains in that area and well how do you
how do you how do you grow them up I
mean you just experienced they just have
to continue to get reps and snaps and
work games and I think that's part of
what we're seeing now is some of those
you know some of those growing pains as
they as they get more experienced right
now on the screen Dean where we're
showing Sean Payton yeah in Los Angeles
this past weekend where Walt Andersen
blew a play dead and he's not what
better in referee and I even tweeted out
like how does that happen
walk me through the like the process of
what the league or al River on again
what you used to do how you would
communicate to somebody as veterans Walt
Andersen like what gives yeah in that
play look that happens they're human and
they're gonna make mistakes from time to
time and it just happened Walt's a good
furry he's been around for a long time
he he understands he'd be the first one
to tell you on and also by the way the
matchup to do it in that matchup it's
like if you're really gonna screw
something up double down do it in the
game next time they play let's go all
out but it's just nice it's you know
wall would be the first one to tell you
cuz what was it was a conference
coordinator for the big 12 for a lot of
years and tart officials he'd be the
first one to say if you're not sure let
them let it play out right and replay
can always come back versus making it a
pass now you take away a touchdown and
it changes the game so now we're 33
games into the world of pass
interference being reviewable how do you
think it's gone so far game it's I mean
I didn't I didn't like the rule going in
and and and it's just it's such a
subjective call and I feel like the rule
went in to fix the Saints Rams play
correct and so it's a safety net for
that but now we're getting involved in
plays that aren't that play the Dalvin
cook yeah hold up that wasn't called on
the field a flag was put down by replay
in replay and it wasn't a challenge from
a coach and it was a scoring play cuz
all scoring plays were there even an
outcry had that call not been made had
no there no there wouldn't and I feel
like we're we're loaded for bear and
we're hunting mice right now it just
doesn't make any sense in terms of that
that obvious mistake and look it's not
an easy call I think it's shining a
spotlight on pass interference what is
and what isn't and it's a one-year deal
so I think if it continues the way it's
going now I don't know if it's gonna
make another year well you know what
coaches think and how they think and the
influence they have on on the membership
that votes on this yeah what do you are
you hearing anything right now
do you I think what the coaches want I
think what they wanted back in March was
they wanted some form of a safety net
just for all not just pass interference
but any type of obvious egregious
mistake they wanted we talked about a
sky judge concept
you know whatever that whatever you want
to call it right that's what the coaches
wanted where the competition committee
landed was just in a small subset pass
interference so I think the coaches
would probably want to see it expanded
to other areas no kissing because you
could you know last year right we missed
two false starts that led to touchdowns
those those impact games you can't fix
that but you can't fix a you know Dalvin
cook may be blocking well I think that I
would the thing that I would say is
maybe you don't you don't look for it
unless it's asked to be looked for right
and I understand that there's the last
two minutes that no coaches are allowed
to ask for anything
but to me as you pointed it as you said
moments ago what you say loaded for bear
but you're hunting mice Yeah right just
came up with that by the way
like trademark that that was really
pretty good right off the cuff right off
the dome yeah so so but it was very
appropriate and so the question is is
what would be the fix because there does
have to be no question a safety net so
what happened in the NFC Championship
game never happens again no question and
then I think that's the goal we've got
to prevent that from happening so how do
we do that you know there's a couple of
ways you could do it and to me you know
what I always go back to Bill Belichick
and his suggestion years ago let the
coaches we've got to challenges their
time that's they're tied to timeouts
let us challenge whatever we want at any
point during the game and I know as a
coach I have to save my timeouts or save
my challenges for that critical point at
the end of the game that way you keep it
limited and the coach can decide what is
critical what is important I think
that's one way you do end up sometimes
teams take timeouts the right way and
they're trying to get the ball back and
they would be out of a timeout out of
timeouts late in the game so that's why
you you put the replay official in the
last two minutes but to give the replay
official carte blanche on everything
would be would be
of course but you know Bella check
making that suggestion even though we
could sit here and say why not because
it does sound like why not right that
does sound like something that could be
done the question then is is what
happens if the coach is out of timeouts
or an hour out of challenges and the NFC
Championship game their poll has a truck
drive through it again
yeah the league officer do you give the
replay official hey won a one-off
opportunity if the team is out of
challenges that they could fix something
but then it comes down the judgment what
is egregious what it's so there's
there's no simple fix and this is
something you know when I was at the
league office we we contemplated I know
the competition company is thinking
about it now and and and at some point
we have to accept that it's not perfect
and they're gonna make mistakes at times
you just hope you can mitigate those
mistakes and prevent them from happening
you know at the end of a close game I
think a scoring plate not that pass
interference you just remove it from the
bucket of any time something's reviewed
everything's reviewable just not pass
interference maybe we could start with
that because you know I mean that way
what happened in Green Bay to Minnesota
doesn't happen but Pete Carroll can
still say hey you missed that pass
interference in Pittsburgh that we
really need that first and four throws a
challenge flag the question is though is
when he did get the flag put down by
replay that said you're right we should
have called it in real-time and he gets
the pass interference that one then I'm
as a fan seeing something similar happen
and say Baltimore and it doesn't get
called it's really confusing and that's
the subjectivity in this call that's
that it's not remember replay was put in
for objective fact the ball touching the
ground right the the knee hitting the
ground now it's well is there contact
before the ball arrived was that contact
enough to restrict the receivers ability
to make a play on the ball so it's very
subjective and it's hard to be truly
consistent from game to game so in a few
minutes I have left through the year in
the Honda inside a report would you do
Dean Blandino what about people who go
in the other direction and say just get
rid of replay what do you say to people
I'm saying we're not we're not gonna go
back I mean we knew I mean I was at the
league office in 1999 when we put replay
back in and it was George Young you know
who was who was the GM for the Giants
for a long time and worked at the league
office and a legend in the NFL and he's
the one that said it he said once we put
this in right it's going to expand and
we'll never we'll never be able to bring
it back and I think people have Hex have
accepted replay I think overall it's
been good for the game imagine imagine a
touchdown counting when it shouldn't
have counted right having no ability to
fix that so I think it is good but we
just have to we have to manage it and
balance between you know the obvious
mistake and and the human element that
because rules are they're written for
officials to make decisions in real time
and what about spotting the ball where
are we in terms of the technology
instead of the eye test of a of a say a
side judge reline judge running behind
the play yeah and then catching up and
just estimating where the spot is these
guys and ladies do a great job most of
the time sometimes not what about the
technology using maybe the the chip the
next-gen that's already in the ball too
sure he has this baby yeah they've been
they've been experimenting with that you
do you know you do have to I mean where
do you put the chip because if it's the
nose of the ball aside if there's so
many things to consider columns we want
to get that do we want to get that
perfect I don't know I don't know maybe
we could review the chip we could review
the chip where it was and where was the
chip in the ball let's take a look let's
go to our next ginge stat the player
would have to have chips all over his
body because you blow down them in the
show whatever the shoulder pads okay
your pod good calls with Dean Blandino
what's your pot about sir it's about
officiating rules obviously we you know
we just started we've had two episodes
we getting some good guess I had Jay
Glazer on and you
Jake how'd you get glaze my leis you
know he's the he's a busy guy yes by the
way I'm very busy okay we're gonna talk
you know we'll talk football we'll talk
other sports and the other thing we're
gonna we're also going to talk a little
life rules okay what are the rules in
certain situations yeah so yeah guys not
just football see I can tell you
elevator etiquette I could tell you
plane traveling by the way you've gotta
get me on as a guest I'd love for you to
cover that because Footwear on a plane
we got to talk about this 100% okay
there's so many different arm rests like
what are the rule others there's so many
different right we didn't we we had
something that went don't be crazy right
viral yeah so if you're sitting in the
middle seat do you get both arm rests
both you get both if you're in the
middle you get both 100% now I don't
know I mean you're in the middle you get
well then how do you get you get the
back do you get the body bird calls
right now I know that's whoever gets
there first whoever gets there it's
first-come first-serve that's not right
I mean some people who were middle seat
aren't gonna be maybe boarding seat you
know group wanted if you get up to that
right can you can you reclaim it sure
that's your penalty for getting up okay
that's not bad that's not bad
I throw the challenge flag there too
many challenge I try I throw the
challenge flag on that I think that's
reviewable you got to get Hockley on
your show right will that do it yes are
you I'm good desire on great terms I've
always liked that okay yeah who's your
favorite ref come on my favorite ref
head referee yes sure um sure that's a
tough one
there's so they're all great guys I mean
come on just tell me one I'll give you
I'll give you Bill vinovich bill
vinovich yeah okay yeah Vinny's great
his his face is always so contorted you
know like like he just yeah you know
everyone who's listening NFL Network
says I will not believe I'll go there he
does always have the look on his face
that somebody just cut the cheese around
him and he's just
yeah baby then you know what I mean like
he does always have that look I'll have
to look for that now
yeah maybe maybe there's a guy on his
crew that has flat chill who's the guy
who was why am i blanking on his name
right now
he retired years ago he's from Minnesota
Oh referee Bernie Kukoc Bernie cool car
man
Bernie Koo car was the best Bernie Koo
car was my favorite Bernie great car
went to the went to the monitor when
they were looking at the monitors yeah
and turned his hat backwards and then
stuck his head it was amazing course
it's burning it's amazing Bernie Koo car
could do what everyone he could cou car
mania just like Mincha mania thanks for
coming on sir you got you can go get
good calls with Dean bland do you know
wherever podcast radio a podcast so
before I let you go how is this gonna
work out with the holdings are we gonna
I think it's gonna come down I think I
think we're gonna set a record for the
season of the season but but I think
we'll end up somewhere like four four
four and a half a game but the third
quarter of last night's game is going to
become a norm the third and now I think
maybe the third quarter maybe we'll
sprinkle in one or two fouls
I think that'll become the norm so
Brady's tweet will not age well over the
whole season is what you're saying again
I think hopefully it does age well and
he got what he wants okay that's there
you go which by the way would make him
the MVP leader in here already need a
hero we do that's your inside a report
sponsored by the Honda Accord whether
you're headed to the stadium it's just
running out for snacks the Accord gets
you there in comfort and style with a
sophisticated design and high-tech
features like standard Honda sensing the
Accord is the most impressive Honda ever
that's Dean Blandino here on the Rich
Eisen show eight four four two Oh for
riches the number two down for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app